bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct sur notre
antenne
l'audition de fleur pellerin la ministre
est entendu par les sénateurs de la
commission du développement durable sur
la question de l'aménagement numérique
du territoire
cette audition intervient alors que la
commission sénatoriale pour
l'application des lois a entamé ses
travaux pour dresser un bilan des
interventions des collectivités
territoriales en matière de numérisation
du territoire français il s'agit en
effet pour les sénateurs et bien de se
pencher sur la question du déploiement
du très haut débit tout de suite donc
sans plus tarder l'audition de fleur
pellerin bon après midi à tous mes chers
collègues je pense que nous allons
pouvoir donc écouter madame la ministre
fleur pellerin donc qui est ministre
délégué auprès du ministre du
redressement productif chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises de
l'innovation et de l'économie numérique
voile alors madame la ministre bienvenus
ça fait environ six mois que nous avons
déjà donc auditionné ici même et donc
c'est avec plaisir que nous vous
recevons nouveau puisque vous savez
notre commission est en charge notamment
de l'amiante territoire et bien sûr de
ce fait suit avec beaucoup d'attention
la politique gouvernement dans votre
secteur de compétence et bien sûr les
élus locaux sont en attente que nous
représentons sont en attente bien sûr en
particulier sur ce problème du
déploiement du numérique qui est
évidemment
une question à la fois central et je
veux dire vital pour les territoires
ruraux en particulier donc la commission
de suivi de l'application des lois qui
est ici présente que je salue en lien
avec notre commission ont confié à
monsieur yves rome et à faire les ont un
rapport pour faire le point sur le rôle
des collectivités locales en matière la
maison eric et leurs conclusions
devraient être disponibles fin janvier
début février
nous savons par ailleurs que vous êtes
en phase de consultation avant l'
annonce qui est prévu d'après nos
informations mi février 2013 du
programme du gouvernement sur la
couverture numérique du territoire
donc bien sûr nous sommes aujourd'hui
curieux de savoir s'il ya quelques
semaines de cette échéance
vous pouvez nous donner des informations
sur les premières orientations que vous
allez retenir
comment envisagez vous de respecter
l'engagement du président de la
république auquel bien sûr nous
souscrivons tous et donc qui prévoit une
couverture par le haut débit de
l'ensemble du territoire d'ici dix ans
vous le savez pardon très haut débit
quand vous le savez bien vous avez
remarqué déjà comment cette partie de
l'auditoire est très attentif alors
malheureusement les choses n'ont pas
beaucoup avancé et le sénat est bien
placé pour le savoir puisqu'il a été à
la fois déçu à la fois peut-être
certainement surtout frustré de ne pas
avoir de réponse à cette interrogation
de savoir comment nous allons financer
ce programme
et bien sûr dans quel délai nous allons
pouvoir le mettre à neuf voilà donc nous
sommes vous l'imaginez tous très
impatients de vous entendre et si vous
voulez bien nous disposons environs
d'une heure trente
donc je vous propose de fermer sur
l'introduction et que nous passions
ensuite aux questionnements
nous avons déjà une longue liste de deux
pétitionnaires pour ces questions voilà
merci madame alice
si monsieur président alors je vous prie
d'avoir de m'excuser parce que j'ai un
comme le sénateur testons je suis malade
et j'espère que ma voix va tenir jusque
jusqu'au bout de cet échange
sinon je suis chaud très dans le micro
alors pour pour juste pour faire un bref
mot d'introduction parce
qu'effectivement je pense qu'il vaut
mieux laisser tout ça perd ça les change
entre nous ensuite je voudrais
concentrer mon propos sur le sujet du
déploiement du très haut débit qui je
pense sera au coeur de deux sets de cet
échange aujourd'hui plus précisément sur
l'aménagement numérique du territoire
thématiques à laquelle votre commission
et tout particulièrement attaché dans
l'aménagement du territoire contient
évidemment une dimension numérique
puisqu'il ya une fracture numérique vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le président
qu'il faut résorber entre territoires
ruraux et territoires urbains mais aussi
parfois au sein des territoires urbains
où on trouve des poches oublié sur le
banc
sur le plan du numérique j'ai eu
l'occasion de détailler à plusieurs
reprises des orientations du
gouvernement en matière de très haut
débit notamment le 22 novembre dernier
lors de l'examen à l'assemblée la
proposition de loi du sénateur maurey
alors je voudrais juste m'attarder un
petit instant sur sur ce point cette
proposition noah avait je crois une
immense vertu d'avoir joué le rôle
d'aiguillon de catalyseur pour le
gouvernement
je crois que la raison pour laquelle
cette proposition a également été
rejetée c'est qu'elle s'inscrivait dans
un calendrier qui ne pouvaient pas nous
permettre de de l'adopter au moment où
allemand a les idées plus claires et
manifeste son volontarisme sur ce
chantier structurant je crois que cette
proposition de loi comporte un certain
nombre de carences juridique qui les
dangers économiques qui ne pouvait
constituer une réponse suit table et
surtout pérenne mais je tiens quand même
à souligner le travail excellent qui a
été effectué par par les sénateurs dans
le cadre de du rapport et de la haie de
la proposition de loi alors il déclaré
volontarisme la couverture de notre
territoire en très haut débit à horizon
de 10 ans était effectivement là le
quatrième rang des engagements de
campagne du président de la république
françois hollande c'est une priorité de
l'action gouvernementale avec comme cab
la compétitivité de notre pays
en agissant des éléments de méthode et
de calendrier pour vous dire ce qui a
été fait depuis
depuis six mois une première version de
la feuille de route est en cours de
finalisation par la mission très haut
débit dont je parlerai tout à l'heure et
sera soumise à la concertation dès la
semaine prochaine voire dès la fin de
cette semaine
la feuille de route définitive sera
finalisée courant janvier et sera
formellement adopté par le gouvernement
lors du séminaire gouvernemental sur le
numérique de la fin du mois de février
dès le lendemain de ce séminaire
différents comités seront convoqués pour
étudier les nouveaux dossiers des
collectivités et la mission se tiendra
dès le mois de janvier à la disposition
de toutes les collectivités qui en
exprimeront le besoin pour les
accompagner notamment tenir compte de la
nouvelle doctrine d'accompagnement des
projets alors les éléments principaux de
la feuille de route pour les projets
privés le gouvernement veillera
je les ai rappelés déjà à ce que soit
clarifié les engagements pris par les
opérateurs
au delà des simples déclarations
d'intention quant aux projets publics
il faudra les accompagner les rendre
viable sur un plan industriel
alors plutôt que des contraintes
excessives qui gèlerait les
investissements et ferait perdre du
temps au déploiement du très haut débit
en france la collection que je souhaite
mettre en avant c'est que la politique
du très haut débit a besoin d'un
pilotage claire et affirmée par par
l'état et donc aujourd'hui la structure
de pilotage est une réalité sa
constitution est en cours elle pourra
s'appuyer sur des compétences qui seront
issus des administrations d'état major
des collectivités locales et puis des
services déconcentrés de l'état
notre volonté est temps d'apporter des
réponses très concrètes à toutes les
questions légitimes que se posent
notamment les collectivités locales le
déploiement du très haut débit suppose
par ailleurs que nous ayons un modèle
économique performant ce modèle
économique c'est celui qui permet à
chacun d'être dans son rôle et à chacun
d'avoir un véritable intérêt à avancer
c'est à dire à investir c'est aussi
celui qui permet à l'état et aux
collectivités de ne pas investir à fond
perdu et d'utiliser au mieux chaque euro
de dépense publique en s'appuyant sur
une véritable dynamique industrielle et
donc sur la bonne complémentarité entre
opérateurs privés et réseaux
d'initiative publique
enfin ce nouveau modèle économique c'est
celui qui se fixe comme objectif la
réduction de la fracture numérique et
qui organise une véritable péréquation
entre les territoires danse et les
territoires les moins denses donc aucune
des questions clés du chantier de du
très haut débit ne sera négligé ni le
financement ni la coopération public
privé ni encore les objectifs de
couverture sur le financement notre
réponse s'appuiera sur deux volets la
subvention et les prêts l'instruction
technique
avant ça n'est pas évidente vous
l'imaginez bien dans le contexte
budgétaire actuel
mais les gouvernements apportera des
réponses rapidement en tout état de
cause d'ici février en abondant le fant
ou un système équivalent nous mettrons
également dès février en place des prêts
pour les collectivités qui se lance dans
le métier du très haut débit
ces prêts nous ne parlons plus seulement
des 300 millions d'euros dû voler à du
guichet à qui pourraient être mis à
disposition des collectivités mais nous
parlons comme l'a annoncé président de
la république des 20 me
d'euros des fonds d'épargné collectés en
octobre qui seront mis à disposition des
collectivités pour des projets dans le
domaine des transports en commun des
réseaux de distribution du traitement de
l'eau et des infrastructures numériques
à très haut débit
donc on mobilisera fortement les fonds
des pannes et c'est précisément sur
l'ingénierie financière des des produits
financiers qui seront proposées aux
collectivités locales que la structure
la mission très haut débit est en train
de travailler actuellement sur la
coopération public-privé et bien il
faudra une contractualisation
systématique état collectivités
opérateurs y compris sur les zones très
denses donc l'état accompagnera bien sûr
ensuite les collectivités qui en auront
besoin
je crois qu'après 10 ans d'absence de
politique nationale d'aménagement
numérique l'état se dote véritablement
des moyens d'accompagner les
collectivités je pense au suivi des
déploiements des opérateurs à
l'accompagnement de l'harmonisation
technique avec le groupe interop fibre
qui regroupe l'ensemble des opérateurs
qui vont déployer des réseaux fibre en
france mais aussi au rôle de conseil
qu'il pourra jouer pour les
collectivités qui qui le souhaiteront et
qui souhaiteront faire appel à c'est à
cette mission de conseil sur la
couverture sur les objectifs de
couverture du territoire
le gouvernement a fait un choix clair un
celui de la fibre optique
mais la bascule du cuivre vers la fibre
vous le savez tous est aussi un chantier
qui se prépare un qui s'organise à
l'avance alors c'est ce à quoi nous
avons commencé déjà à nous atteler avec
un test en grandeur nature à palaiseau
dont vous s'agit vous savez qu'il s'agit
d'une première mondiale
c'est important de le souligner le
chantier de la bascule vers la fibre
optique c'est un chantier vraiment
titanesque un chantier industriel majeur
avec des implications très forte en
terme d'emploi en terme de formation je
leur dis donc ici à l'occasion de ce de
cet échange de ce débat la réponse du
gouvernement est bien qu'il y aura une
extinction du cuivre elle mais celle ci
devrait être progressive et dans un
calendrier et des modalités qui seront
précisées
après l'expérimentation de palaiseau qui
va durer environ 18 mois le très haut
débit partout et pour tous et donc
l'objectif à 10 ans pour autant je sais
qu'il faudra répondre à l'attenté de nos
concitoyens sans attendre 2022
et c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé de
définir des cibles prioritaires qui
devront être desservis d'ici la fin du
quinquennat
qu'il s'agisse de zones résidentielles
des zones résidentielles les moins bien
mais aussi des zones rurales des zones
d'activités économiques où certains
sites publics comme les hôpitaux ou les
établissements scolaires et donc les
projets pourront ainsi procédé dans ce
cadre là d'une montée vers le très haut
débit c'est à dire dans un premier temps
comporter une part de ftn à condition
toutefois de se placer dans une
perspective de déploiement du ftth à
terme
voilà donc feu à grands traits ce que je
souhaitais dire dans mon propos
liminaire tout en vous précisant que
dans le temps d'échanger avec vous les
sujets telecom et une couverture en
téléphonie mobile pourront aussi
évidemment être être abordés sont qui va
nous permettre d'ouvrir le débat et
c'est michel teston qui ouvre ses yeux
le président madame la ministre vous
venez de formuler certain nombre de
propositions liées à la première version
de la feuille de route pour ce qui nous
concerne moi je souhaite donner ma
vision du plan national très haut débit
dans sa forme actuelle est formulé aussi
un certain nombre de propositions de
suggestions pour pour le réviser
s'agissant du plan national très haut
débit
nous avons toujours dit en particulier
en ce qui concerne le groupe que
socialiste que nous trouvions qu'il ce
plan manquait de volontarisme et qui
laissait la part trop belle aux
opérateurs et il leur permet notamment
par des opérateurs en annonçant des
investissements de pouvoir bloquer les
initiatives des collectivités
territoriales et c'est d'autant plus
grave que ce plan ne prévoit aucune
sanction
si les opérateurs ne tiennent pas leurs
engagements ce plan a également le grand
inconvénient de cantonner les
collectivités territoriales ou zones
très peu denses et enfin le fonds
d'aménagement numérique du territoire
qui a été créée par la proposition de
loi pintât n'a jamais été alimentées
alors bien sûr il convient de revoir ce
plan comme vous venez de l'indiquer ceci
étant il me semble que le plan a été
notifiée ont semble t'il à l'union
européenne à la commission européenne et
que donc les opérateurs ont par ailleurs
engagé déjà un certain nombre
d'investissements en particulier
s'agissant de la
donc ça m'amène à formuler un certain
nombre de propositions pour la révision
de ce plan je partirai de l'idée que ce
qui est essentiel sur ce dossier c'est
que l'état reprenne la main puisqu'en
fait il l'a laissé avec le plan national
très haut débit aux opérateurs alors
quelques idées pour pour la zone 2
reprendre la mer mon sens ça veut dire
qu'il faut il faut pas attendre le délai
de cinq ans qui est beaucoup trop long
et qu'il faut mettre en place un vrai
constat de carence afin de permettre aux
collectivités de s'engager si les
opérateurs finalement ne tiennent pas
leurs engagements
je crois qu on leur a laissé là vraiment
une latitude beaucoup trop grand
s'agissant du financement vous avez
évoqué madame la ministre
les possibilités de subventionnement et
de près moi je me demande s'il faut pas
quand même évoquer à nouveau même si
c'est pas toujours très plaisant à la
question de la taxation est peut-être
que il ne sera pas forcément nécessaire
de créer une nouvelle taxation parce que
je crois savoir qu un recours a été
introduit dans la cour de justice de
l'union européenne contre la taxe dite
copé portant sur les opérateurs de
télécommunication et qui vise à financer
l'audiovisuel vous rappeler c'est quand
la publicité avait été effectivement
supprimées ou réduites et à ce jour si
les informations dont je dispose sont
exactes cette taxe rapporterait 250
millions d'euros
je crois qu'ils auraient pas les mêmes
difficultés si effectivement à la cour
de justice européenne
sanctionné en quelque sorte ce
dispositif pour pouvoir l'affecter
finalement au financement du très haut
débit puisque ce serait les opérateurs
eux mêmes qui en quelque sorte serait
serait directement concernés et la paire
est donc sûrs et un lien évident avec
l'objet même finalement de cette taxe
voilà sur le troisième le troisième
suggestion faire en sorte contrôle des
dispositifs pour pouvoir aller vers une
coopération entre le secteur public et
le secteur privé
ça me paraît possible en particulier
dans la zone 3 dans la mesure où là
les règles de la concurrence ne sont pas
véritablement prépondérante
je pense que sur ce territoire là on
peut envisager sans aucun doute sous
réserve de l'accord de l'autorité de la
concurrence ce qu'on puisse trouver des
partenariats entre finalement opérateurs
privés et collectivités et faire en
sorte que les opérateurs au fur à mesure
qu'ils gagneront de l'argent donc sur le
secteur 1 puissent effectivement
intervenir aussi aux côtés des
collectivités dans la zone 2-3 ça serait
à mon avis un bon exemple et qui ne me
paraît pas je vous le redis porter
atteinte aux sacro-saintes et règles de
la concurrence auxquelles je suis
attaché mais mais mais sans plus dans ce
secteur-là quand on sait très bien que
c'est plus une question d'aménagement du
territoire la queue de respect des
règles de la concurrence
si monsieur yves rome bien madame la
ministre
ravi de voir que le sujet progresse et
avance en tout cas l'expression que vous
nous avez adressé en témoignent assez
largement
toutefois je voudrais insister sur la
nécessité qu'il y as d'arrêter j'ai
indiqué fin février la feuille de route
précise claire et objective pour que les
collectivités territoriales intéressées
à l'atteinte de l'objectif que le
président de la république a positionné
au quatrième rang de ses engagements
connaissent un début effectif nombre de
collectivités qui sont aujourd'hui
intéressés à l'atteinte de cet objectif
qui se sont déjà engagés sont un peu
l'armé au pied
puisque le plan national très haut débit
précédent avait au delà des défauts que
vient de souligner très précisément mon
collègue testant avait toutefois permis
l'engagement d'un certain nombre de
collectivités territoriales qui avait
soumissionné
elles étaient au moins au nombre de onze
départements et régions soumissionner
pour être éligible
aux 900 millions d'euros débloqués au
titre du grand emprunt a aujourd'hui
seuls 266 millions d'euros ont été
débloqués au bénéfice de ces
collectivités
d'autres un grand nombre ont adopté leur
schéma d'aménagement numérique de leur
territoire majoritairement d'ailleurs
des collectivités départementales
il faudra je vous l'indiquais de manière
un peu rapide veiller à ce que les
évolutions concernant les nouvelles
règles la nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation ne crée pas une
autorité supérieure qui viendraient
interdire aux collectivités
départementales d'assurer leur
déploiement j'ai pu lire de ci de là des
éléments qui de ce point de vue ne me
rassure guère à aucun moment je ne
souhaite voir les collectivités
départementales placés sous la coupe des
régions qui devraient assurer
l'interopérabilité des réseaux déployés
dans les départements dans les régions
parce qu'à ce moment là faudrait aussi
allaient s'interroger sur les frontières
des régions entre elles et je vois pas
de ce point de vue de mon vous l'avez
rappelé j'espère que vous y veillerai
c'est le retour de l'état stratège qu'on
a besoin et les collectivités ont besoin
c'est ce qui faisait défaut et je le
sais que mon collègue mort et ne déplore
pas suffisamment mais je sais qu'au fond
de lui même
ils pensent à peu près la même chose
c'était l'absence d'un état stratège qui
définisse de manière très précise les
modalités du déploiement de façon à
éviter le prétexte un peu malins que les
opérateurs us parfois pour éviter soit
de déployer soit de devenir clients des
réseaux d'initiative publique
une fois que la norme une
standardisation sera fixée de manière
très précise par l'état ce type
d'arguties n'aura plus de bise
par contre j'ai bien noté dans votre
propos est
collecter ce ton-là appelé lui même qui
a nécessité d'aller vérifier non pas de
bouleverser comme certains l'avaient
imaginée pendant entend larchitecture
qui avait été précédemment betty même si
elle était incomplète elle avait le
mérite d'avoir lancé la mécanique
aujourd'hui la proposition que vous
semblez nous faire c'est de dire qu'il
faut que sur les zones amis ou les
opérateurs c'est à dire la zone tout
simplement où les opérateurs ont déclaré
des intentions d'investissement ne sont
pas très nombreux il était que deux
puisque seul france télécom et sfr ont
préempté season amis sauf cas
aujourd'hui à part france télécom
pardonnez moi monsieur mauvais mais à
part france télécom
c'est le seul opérateur qui est déployer
de la fibre dans les zones qu'il avait
présenté même si c'est notoirement
insuffisant qu'il faudra aller vérifier
la réalité de leur engagement quelles
sont les conditions dans lesquelles ils
ont commencé à déployer et puis vous
l'avez précisé contractualiser sur la
base de ses engagements dans une
dimension ternaire avec à la fois bien
sûr les collectivités territoriales car
pour déployer le sol des collectivités
territoriales et c'est elle qui la
maîtrisent le devenir avec l'état qui
aura redéfinir son rôle de stratège et
d'aiguillon et bien entendu les
opérateurs eux-mêmes qui doivent quelle
est la réalité et la mobilisation des
investissements en matière financière et
dans le temps qu'ils devront engager
parce qu'il faut pas que cette opération
perdure pour finir dans les sables et à
défaut dans la durée qu'ils auront
eux-mêmes contractualisés eh bien les
territoires qu'il n'aura pas
et si en matière de fibrage retombe
auront tout naturellement dans le champ
de la zone de celles des collectivités
territoriales par contre ce qui faisait
défaut précédents plans même s'il avait
quelques avantages c'est d'avoir créé un
fonds sans fronts puisque le fant reste
à ce jour non alimentaire à part les 900
millions d'euros dont la consommation
gelé précisé n'a pas été totale et
peut-être lure et la nécessité a
récupéré ses formes d'investissements
d'avenir pour accompagner les
collectivités actuelles mais il
n'empêche que tant que les collectivités
territoriales n'aurons pas la certitude
d'un financement pérenne et sécurisée
dans le temps on aura du mal à
consolider la volonté d'investissement
est donc important alors quel que soit
le véhicule utilisé pour les aborder le
fond de moi nous avons quelques
préférences qui sont parfois les idées
simples mais souvent les idées simples
sont les plus difficiles à mettre en
oeuvre de prélever un demi centime
d'euro sur les abonnements fixes et
mobiles qui permettrait
significativement d'arriver au bon
niveau que nous estimons utile à savoir
entre 700 et 800 millions d'euros en
pour permettre aux collectivités
territoriales l'atr assurés qu'ils
seront accompagnés et accompagner de
manière inégalitaire pas comme c'était
le cas précédemment au titre du fonds de
la société numérique où le taux moyen
était à peu près identique 20 22 %
malgré les annonces
parce qu'il faut tenir compte des
inégalités territoriales et de la
capacité aussi des collectivités
territoriales qui sont inégales en
termes de richesse ensuite bien entendu
c'est le choix que vous avez réaffirmé
le choix de la fibre qui est la solution
pérenne d'avenir et qui pourra permettre
je le crois à la nation française à la
fois de développer sa filière
industrielle qui est aujourd'hui
légèrement difficultés au vu du retard
qu'on a accumulée dans le déploiement du
très haut débit pour sécuriser ainsi les
industriels
et puis bien entendu développer
parallèlement je crois il faudra éviter
de tomber dans ce piège un peu
théorique de l'opposition entre les
usagers les réseaux les uns nourrissent
les autres et les uns sont nécessaires
aux autres pour pouvoir développer cette
filière qui aujourd'hui partout dans le
monde
créer la valeur nous le voyons bien
d'ailleurs avec la grande difficulté que
l'état nation à à prélever le juste
impôt sur la valeur que dégage des
principaux opérateurs internationaux qui
sont tous d'origine d'outre-atlantique
des fameux gafa comme les dénomme si
bien mon collègue sénateur de l'oise
philippe marini
il y a là aussi cette nécessité oui je
sais qui est attentive à développer tout
l'écosystème du numérique qui en soi va
permettre en développement massif des
usages en tout cas l'avenir nous serons
très attentifs à ce que le rôle des
collectivités territoriales qui a été
déterminant dans la mise à haut débit du
territoire national puisse aujourd'hui
accompagné significativement l'état dans
l'atteinte de l'objectif fixé
je rappelle à 10 ans par le président la
république lui-même
nous avons déjà écoulé la moitié d'une
année c'est peut-être pas trop tard mais
mon point de vue il est temps de ne pas
perdre six mois supplémentaires
merci monsieur hervé maurey
merci monsieur le président j'ai pas de
divergences fondamentales avec ceux des
deux collègues précédent viennent
d'exprimer c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'on a voté ici même la même
proposition de loi que j'avais cosigné
avec philippe leroy ici présents j'ai un
peu plus de divergences peut-être avec
mon collègue yves rome parce qu'il est
un peu plus optimiste que moi en voyant
du changement là où personnellement je
n'en vois aucun j'avais cru comprendre
madame la ministre quand vous avez pris
vos fonctions il ya maintenant sept mois
que le changement c'était pour
maintenant objectivement en sept mois
rien n'a changé sur le haut débit rien
n'a changé sur la téléphonie mobile
rien n'a changé sur le très haut débit
et cette déception elle a été renforcée
et elle est presque devenu de de
l'amertume même si je n'aime pas
beaucoup ce mot
depuis le 22 novembre date à laquelle
vous avez fait enterrer notre
proposition de loi qui avait été voté à
la quasi unanimité du sénat à
l'assemblée nationale chers collègues
yves rome l'avait voté aussi alors je ne
prétends pas que cette proposition de
loi elle était la panacée que c'était la
pierre philosophale qui allait tout
régler et je vous avais dit qu'elle
pouvait naturellement être amendé
complète et corrigée voir différé dans
son examen pour vous laisser le temps de
terminer vos vos investigations du sujet
mais ce qui m'a beaucoup choqué c'est
les mots extrêmement durs et et même
violent que vous avez utilisé en disant
je vous cite que c'était un texte
idéologique et court termiste que les
propositions étaient inutiles et
inefficaces que le texte était sous
dimensionné et décalé allant jusqu à
nous reprocher que nous n'ayons pas
régler la question du financement dans
cette proposition de loi
alors que chacun sait très bien ici que
c'est la période pré électorale qui a
conduit je vais dire l'ensemble des
groupes politiques pour être désagréable
avec personne a refusé que l'on traite
la question du
du financement dans cette proposition de
loi vous avez repris la parole sur
chaque article où vous avez déposé des
amendements de suppression
là encore dans des termes extrêmement
violent sur la téléphonie mobile pour
vous il n'y a pas de sujet tout est
réglé si on lit ce que vous avez dit sur
le haut débit vous avez dit qu'il y
avait déjà une solution satellitaire qui
offrait du haut débit pour tous à 2
mégas donc là aussi tout est réglé
circulez ya rien à voir
sur la contractualisation vous avez
repris les arguments qu'ils étaient ceux
de votre prédécesseur selon lesquelles
il ne fallait surtout pas contrarier les
opérateurs et que si on s'engage et de
la contractualisation ça risquait de
décourager l'investissement je vous cite
est naturellement vous avez refusé toute
idée que les engagements des opérateurs
ne puissent le non respect des
engagements des opérateurs puissent être
sanctionnés
donc vous avez procédé je le dis avec un
peu de violence que j'ai eu c'est vrai
que c'est assez décourageant pour tout
le travail qui a été fait par le sénat
qui avait adopté à l'unanimité un
rapport qui avait adopté à la quasi
unanimité une proposition doit vous avez
enterré ce texte avec beaucoup de de
violence et de mépris avec des arguments
encore une fois que j'avais entendu dans
d'autres bouches que la vôtre jusqu'à
présent alors aujourd'hui vous avez
voulu nous mettre un petit peu de baume
au coeur vous avez quelques mots
aimables sur notre travail
vous avez dégager quelques quelques
pistes sur ce que vous comptiez faire en
matière de très haut débit j'ai même
entendu des mots que vous aviez condamné
pourtant il ya quelques jours au à
l'assemblée nationale comme la
contractualisation
en revanche je n'ai toujours rien
entendu sur ce que vous comptiez faire
en matière de haut débit
or dieu sait que je suis un partisan du
très haut débit
mais on peut pas déployer le très haut
débit en laissant encore des populations
de même pas avoir du haut débit mois
corps dans mon département je parle de
haut débit de très haut débit on dit
écoute
c'était gentil et que l'on très haut
débit mais si tu pouvais déjà nous avoir
dû à un ou deux méga en serais content
donc quid là dessus est-ce qu'il faut
s'en référer à ce qu a dit à l'assemblée
nationale c'est à dire qu' aucun
problème puisque tout le monde a déjà dû
du 2 mégas grâce à la solution
satellitaire quid de la téléphonie
mobile
il est je vous rappelle que à notre
demande votre prédécesseur avait
installé une groupe de travail pour
essayer de 2,2 d'améliorer la manière
dont on mesure la couverture en
téléphonie mobile et je vous avais
demandé lors de votre précédente
audition demande confirmée par un écrit
au mois de septembre reste est sans
objet ça aussi c'est un point commun
avec votre prédécesseur
on ne répond pas aux courriers je vous
avais demandé que ce groupe de travail
puisse se remettre au travail parce que
ils n'avaient débouché sur rien du tout
et c'est me semble-t-il important donc
quid sur la téléphonie mobile
et puis dernière question on a parlé
tout à l'heure et notamment à travers
une question d'yves rome de
l'interopérabilité et des compétences de
la région par rapport aux départements
voyez aussi quelque chose qui me soucie
c'est que dans un certain nombre de
départements les conseils généraux se
défausse sur les communautés de communes
et je pense que la communauté de
communes
surtout dans une petite communauté de
communes rurales n'a pas la compétence
technique ni l'assise financière mais ça
existe sur hommes pour le faire donc je
crois qu'il faudrait je crois qu'il
faudrait que l'état puisque je m'en
réjouis et vous dites que l'état doit
reprendre la main et jouer son rôle d'
état stratège devrait sans doute mettre
le holà à ces pratiques
merci monsieur retail ou bien juste un
constat
je pense entre nous que je parle des
sénateurs on doit pouvoir sur un sujet
qui doit pas faire l'objet d'une
politique politicienne mais qui est un
grand chantier national on doit pouvoir
sur un sujet aussi fondamental trouver
des points d'accord et c'est ce que je
dirai dans quelques instants
je regrette juste le ministre veut pas
renouveler la charge que vient de faire
nos collègues hervé bondir quand dix ans
il ne s'est rien passé
au fond c'est une facilité de rhétorique
dans la limite pourquoi pas mais ça
correspond pas ça ne correspond pas à la
réalité vous savez d'abord parce que
genre de truc maintenant plus personne
n'y croit
ça devra là on a beau jeter ce genre
d'invectivés dans une assemblée bon là
ça fait partie des figures de style
obligé peut-être ça ne fait pas avancer
le débat et je pense même que là dessus
il faut qu'on arrive à trouver des
points d'entente et ces points d'entente
ils sont parfaitement trouvable si j'ose
dire le première question qui concerne
le plan national sur le très haut débit
dans cette première question de deux
volets le volet du financement je suis
assez d'accord aussi bien avec yves rome
que avec la proposition de michel teston
moi j'ai toujours indiqué que dans le
cas où la taxe ne n'aurais pas l'aval de
bruxelles
il y aura une vraie logique à ce qu'ils
puissent financer le fonds bon le thym
en revanche si on doit demain créer un
abonnement de 50 centimes à part dans
une taxe sur les abonnements fixes et
mobiles 50 centimes
pourquoi pas donc là si vous voulez on a
deux pistes je pense qu' il vaut mieux
privilégier la première dans un premier
temps pour se donner le temps d'étudier
un peu plus la seconde mais voyez que
sur la question du financement
il ya plus de parts whitehorse et il n'y
a pas de mur de berlin si j'ose dire
entre nous sur sur la première question
sur le très haut débit la collectivité
territoriale
je vois là je préside un exécutif comme
beaucoup d'autres de mes collègues et
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on a un accès
extrêmement dur si au crédit donc ce
serait intéressant qu'on puisse avoir
des prêts vous avez dit que le premier
guichet le guichet à vous et les fonds
de collecte d'épargné vous pouviez les
transformer en prêt je pense que ça peut
nous arranger
j'espère que les départements les
collectivités qui ont déjà fait l'objet
d'un d'un oui d'un accord sur le thd
pourrait en même temps bénéficié de ces
prêts c'est important si c'est le cas à
quel taux se feront ils parce que c'est
pas un problème de de liquidités même si
de temps en temps on a de la peine à
trouver c'est aussi un problème de taux
aujourd'hui donc ça c'est la deuxième
question sur le financement
je rejoins parfaitement mon collègue pas
seulement parce qu'il est présente
conseil général on avait dans la loi
pintât définit comme my essentiel le
département sans pour autant exclure la
malheureuse la maille régionales quand
on a des forte identité je pense par
exemple la bretagne je pense à
l'auvergne
bon bah ya des identités l'alsace
évidemment il ya des identités
régionales qui surplombe naturellement
des identités départementale je vous ai
vu à vous dire qu'en mal à en pays de la
loire avec la vendée l'identité elle est
plutôt avant des conflits de la loire où
je sais que vous connaissez pas
seulement pour le vendée globe mais pour
plein d'autres raisons peu importe
et donc on se positionne parce qu'il ya
moins d'homogénéité que d'autres régions
j'ai lu moi aussi l'avant projet qui
concerne les compétences sur la
décentralisation
ce serait franchement une régression et
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire je défie
quiconque de faire un déploiement avec
cet avant projet de décentralisation je
défie quiconque c'est un principe de
réalité
vous voyez sur ces deux sujets on est
finalement tous près des uns des autres
quelles que soient nos sensibilités je
quitte le programme thd pour dire un mot
de la 4g madame vous savez que je
mettais beaucoup engagé avec le
dividende numérique depuis plusieurs
années et je vois et c'est d'ailleurs
très bien
que les opérateurs puissent faire face à
une concurrence un peu un peu mais
freinée en innovant et en essayant
d'accélérer le déploiement de la 3g
j'ai vu comme vous le programme de
déploiement de la 4g notamment pour 2013
on était pour l'instant sur de
l'expérimentation je considère que sur
2013 on va être sûr de
l'industrialisation de ces j'ose dire ma
question est la suivante pour la
première fois vous savez on a contraint
les opérateurs dans le processus de
distribution d'attribution des
fréquences dans la première pour la
première fois on les a contraints à un
déploiement non seulement dans les
grandes villes mais aussi en zone
prioritaire 18 % du territoire et on
avait indiqué pour que le déploiement
s'effectue simultanément dans les
grandes villes et dans cette zone rurale
prioritaire on l'avait indiqué il y
avait un effet de cliquet qui permettait
qui de fin qui contraignait les
opérateurs à couvrir 40% sur les cinq
premières années
la zone prioritaire ma question est la
suivante je vois bien ou le déploiement
de la 4g va se faire pour l'instant je
ne vois que des grandes villes donc
instruit par la 2g instruit par la 3g et
la 3g + nous comptons sur votre
vigilance pour que dès 2013 vous
signifier aux opérateurs parce que si on
loupe 2013 vous ne tiendrez pas les
engagements je vous assure sur la zone
prioritaire en tout cas ce sera très
très difficiles telles qu'on les avait
prévu dans le processus d'attribution
dernière question pour savoir où on en
est on nous avait indiqué que fin
novembre début décembre le processus de
fusion pas fusion entre les régulateurs
du visuel et sur le numérique et sur les
télécoms pourrait être tranchée et je
voulais savoir aussi c'est mon autre
question où est ce que en et le
gouvernement sur ce point là merci
bien un anneau min si vous voulez
répondre dans ses premières questions
merci au président alors sur les
obligations des opérateurs et le fait
que l'état puisse enfin les questions
liées au constat de carence en fait je
crois que le ce que nous avons annoncé
et je ne crois pas avoir dit que j'étais
opposé à la notion de contrat liées de
contractualisation de nos contraire j'ai
indiqué lors de la discussion à
l'assemblée nationale qu'au contraire
l'état souhaitait justement rendre
passer des déclarations d'intention des
opérateurs à des véritables contrats
tripartites entre les collectivités
locales l'état et les opérateurs pour
garantir justement le déploiement les
investissements et le calendrier
associés à ces investissements
il est bien évident que dans ces
contrats sur lesquels elle a mission
très haut débit est en train de préparer
une sorte de modèle type que chacun
adaptera en fonction des
caractéristiques locales bien évidemment
il y aura des dispositions des clauses
qui concerneront les modalités du
constat de carence et nous souhaitons
effectivement faire en sorte que ce
constat de carence puisse être anticipé
sur sur les 50 go que vous mentionniez
monsieur testons et qu'il puisse être
fait plus tôt
donc ça fera partie des éléments qui
figureront dans les dents les clauses
types du cahier par des conventions des
conventions types que que nous
proposerons aux collectivités
territoriales et que l'état co-signe ira
à leurs côtés sur le financement et donc
là je vais répondre en même temps à
plusieurs questions qui ont été posées
qui effectivement le noeud de la
question sur la question de la taxe copé
c'est une question qui est compliqué
parce qu'à la fois j'entends bien votre
demande et je souhaite moi aussi qu'on
propose un conte puisse proposer un
financement pérenne mais nous sommes
pour l'instant dépendant d'une décision
de la cour de justice sur lequel sur
laquelle le calendrier pour l'instant
n'est pas tout à fait
très clair la décision devait être prise
au premier trimestre de l'année
prochaine puis peut-être au premier
semestre
donc en fait on sait pas très bien quand
la cour de justice va rendre son sa
décision il est je le crois aussi même
si je me garderai bien de d'anticiper
sur cette décision il est assez probable
compte tenu de la rédaction de la
directive télécom que cette taxe sera
sera rejetée par la cour de justice et
que par conséquent c'est bien la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement a dû
provisionner un milliard 3 1 milliards 3
dans le plf 2013 c'est bien pour
rembourser les opérateurs de cette taxe
qui aura été indûment perçues par par
l'état et donc effectivement c'est une
ressource potentielle de l'ordre de 200
entre 200 et 300 millions d'euros par an
donc c'est un rendement qui n'est pas
négligeable qui correspond effectivement
en gros à ce que ne ce dont le
gouvernement aurait besoin pour abonder
un fonds de péréquation qu'il se soit le
ventoux ou un autre instrument mais
c'est à peu près les montants dont nous
aurions besoin sur la période pour pour
alimenter ce fonds de péréquation donc
vous imaginez bien que ce cette idée
nous nous nous est passé par la tête et
que nous surveillons donc avec attention
la décision que prendra la cour de
justice
sachant que vous avez raison de le
souligner dans l'un des actifs télécoms
ce qui vient d'indiquer c'est qu'on ne
peut soumettre les opérateurs télécoms
cas des contributions à des taxes qui
servent à financer la régulation le
déploiement de la fibre peut très bien
faire partie de des dépenses qui
seraient éligibles et je pense que ça
serait tout à fait eurocompatible de
diriger une telle taxe ensuite vers le
financement de la péréquation pour le
déploiement de la fibre
encore une fois on a un petit peu dans
la politique fiction parce que en
attendant d'avoir une réponse de la cour
de justice une décision de la cour de
justice un petit peu difficile de tabler
et d'inscrire en tout cas ce financement
dans le marbre
mais sachez que c'est évidemment une
réflexion que que nous avons alors sur
le reste
vous l'avez souligné monsieur le
sénateur rome il ya effectivement les
guichets a et b de la caisse des dépôts
qui reste du fonds pour la société
numérique qui restent ouverts donc il ya
un milliard de prêts et et 900 millions
de subventions dont tout l'ensemble n'a
pas été n'a pas été dépensée donc pour
l'instant ce fonds bar est ouvert bien
sûr pour les collectivités c'est bien de
la subvention et puis s'agissant du
guichet à le milliard qui n'a pas du
tout été sollicitée par les opérateurs
il y en a un qui va peut-être y faire
appel on est en train de d'examiner la
manière dont on va répartir les
enveloppes pour justement qu'une partie
de leurs de 300 millions puisse être
destinée à des prêts à taux bonifiés je
peux pas vous donner un taux là comme ça
parce qu'on est en train de travailler
sur sur l'ingénierie financière mais ce
sera bien des taux bonifiés et surtout
les durées très longues et dures et
extrêmement longues qui correspondent à
la durée d'amortissement pour pour de
tels investissements et donc qui seront
qui seront offerts ouvert aux
collectivités qui souhaiteront y avoir
recours et il y aura sans doute aussi
une partie de ce milliard qui sera
consacré aux usages parce qu'il nous
semble important de pouvoir avancer de
front effectivement pour pour que bien
la montée en débit s'accompagne aussi de
la montée des usages donc une partie de
ces fonds seront éligibles à des
programmes d'investissement dans des
dans des programmes de déploiement de
développement de l'économie numérique
sur vous avez évoqué la fiscalité vous
avez les acteurs multinationaux les over
the top les gaffes a enfin les acteurs
multinationaux qui ne payent pas d'impôt
sur les sociétés qui ne contribue pas ni
allah ni à la au financement de la
création ni à l'entretien ou à la
création d'infrastructures de
communications électroniques
c'est vous savez l'objet d'une mission
que nous avons lancée et que nous avons
confié à deux personnes
monde du conseil d'état membre de
l'inspection des finances qui
travaillent actuellement c'est un sujet
qui est extrêmement compliqué mais vous
avez bien vu qui n'est pas
franco-français qui agite aussi et qui
perturbe beaucoup nous nos collègues
anglais américains même allemand donc
nous de notre côté nous travaillons à
des solutions nationales
nous avons aussi souhaité réactiver et
nous sommes en train de le faire
actuellement notre participation aux
côtés des allemands et des britanniques
d'ailleurs dans les groupes de travail
de l' ocde qui ont décidé de redonner
une accélération un chantier qui avait
été laissé un peu de côté qui est le
chantier qui s'appelle betts bays
érosion des bases et des placements des
profits qui vise justement à limiter la
possibilité pour des conflits nationaux
d'optimiser leur taxation à l'échelle
mondiale et de placer tous leurs
bénéfices dans des paradis fiscaux en
attendant une amnistie fiscale qui leur
permet de rapatrier leurs leur cash aux
états unis donc nous travaillons et nous
avons décidé d'être moteur sur ces
sujets là avec le cd afin de pouvoir
peut-être réviser des conventions
fiscales bilatérales et là il s'agit de
milliards si jamais nous arrivons à
taxer ces opérateurs et évidemment si
jamais nous devions nous arrivons à
taxer ces opérateurs
il y aura une partie qui sera
vraisemblablement dirigé vers la
création et le financement de la
création mais aussi sur sur les
infrastructures sur les les coopération
public privé dans la zone dans les zones
non denses dans la zone 3 là aussi je
pense que ça fait partie des discussions
que nous avons actuellement avec les
opérateurs et en particulier le
principal opérateur qui sera concerné
par les investissements l'opérateur
historique qui est prêt et qui est prêt
à aller investir dans ces zones
si effectivement les conditions de 2
déquilibre commercial à terme sont
réunis sont des opérateurs privés
donc ils sont évidemment ils ont une
optique de rendement même si c'est un
rendement plus patient dans le cadre
d'un opérateur ou l'état des
participations je pense que le fait de
pouvoir envisager avec le secteur des
télécoms j'ai rien à l'extérieur avec
les questions de 4g un environnement
juridique fiscales stables sur une
certaine période à un accompagnement de
l'état dans les investissements une
participation de l'état sous forme de
subventions et de prêts bonifiés permet
aussi de donner une visibilité
d'ensemble aux opérateurs et d'envisager
de de co investir avec des collectivités
locales y compris dans les zones non
denses et compris dans les zones où a
priori sans l'intervention de l'état ce
ne serait pas rentable mais donc nous
sommes en train de discuter avec france
télécom orange en particulier et il y a
des possibilités bien sûr pour cet
opérateur d'aller co investir dans des
zones dans des zones non denses sur la
loi de décentralisation prend un peu les
questions en fait dans l'ordre mais elle
se recoupent pour certaines d'entre
elles sur la loi de décentralisation bon
on en est effectivement vous l'avais dit
au stade de l'avant-projet
il n'est pas question pour l'instant de
donner une des rares chizé et de donner
une autorité d'une collectivité sur une
autre en matière de déploiement du très
haut débit
nous savons très bien que les situations
locales sont très différents d'une
région à l'autre
on le voit très bien en bretagne et en
auvergne
ou les finalement on a 2 2
un projet qui avance bien mais qui ne
sont pas bâti du tout de la même façon
donc il n'est pas question de donner un
rôle aux régions de d'autorité mais
néanmoins nous souhaitons que l'état
pilote puisse coordonner l'ensemble des
déploiements et donc nous confierons
vraisemblablement aux régions le soin
d'eux puisque lé dann vont devoir être
être pris avant le juillet de l'année
prochaine
le soin de coordonner de faire remonter
les années de veiller qu'aux frontières
il n'y a pas de problème de
l'interopérabilité des réseaux mais
c'est pas c'est pas de la maîtrise
d'ouvragé
c'est juste un ce sera une discussion
qui sera bien sûr au parlement mais mais
il nous semble difficile de faire en
sorte que l'état puisse vérifier
l'interopérabilité département par
département de l'ensemble des décès
d'anne donc il y aura un rôle de
collecte qui sera effectué par les par
les régions c'est plutôt comme ça que
j'ai vu c'est plus un rôle de collecte
d'informations et de remonter de la
formation et puis un rôle aussi
peut-être de négociation vis-à-vis des
opérateurs pour éviter qu'il y ait des
dépenses redondantes qu'ils soient
effectués auprès de cabinets de conseil
ou 2 ou 2 ou de deux fournisseurs de
fibres etc
donc je pense que c'est aussi on
réfléchit aussi en termes d'économies
d'échelle maintenant c'est un avant
projet donc c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui sera discuté dans le cadre de
non seulement de la décentralisation
mais qui pourra l'être également dans la
ensuite dans la feuille de route sur le
sur le très haut débit sur le
déploiement de la vérification du
déploiement des opérateurs
le rôle de
la mission très haut débit ce sera
notamment d'être un observatoire du
déploiement des opérateurs et donc ils
sont en train actuellement de vérifier
l'ensemble des engagements qui ont
d'ores et déjà été pris par les
opérateurs les retards parce que
beaucoup de d'entre vous enfin beaucoup
de collectivités nous ont fait part des
retards qui avaient été pris dans les
investissements réalisés par rapport aux
engagements qui avaient été pris forme
qui avait peu de formaliser dans des
déclarations d'intention ou dans des
conventions
donc nous sommes en train de pointer
actuellement exactement les retards et
et de faire une cartographie en fait des
déploiements et des retards qui sont
pris pour pouvoir ensuite intervenir
donc il ya bien une mission
d'observatoire qui sera mise en place et
qui permettra d'objectiver et de rendre
transparent très transparente à la fois
le déploiement et le calendrier de
déploiement des investissements des
opérateurs alors sur les remarques de du
sénateur mon rêve
pour rappel sénateurs que vous avez été
je crois le premier ou un des premiers
en tout cas parlementaire que j'ai reçus
pour échanger sur sur le très haut débit
vous dites que rien n'a changé sur le
très haut débit
nous avons monté une structure de
pilotage nous sommes en train de mettre
en place des financements pérennes sur
la téléphonie mobile nous sommes en
train de gérer les conséquences de
l'introduction sans étude d'impact de la
quatrième licence mobile d'accélérer le
déploiement de la 4g de travailler sur
le rif hermine de la bande des 1800
d'accélérer les choses sur la bande de
800 donc je pense que nous ne faisons
pas rien et je pense qu'il ya vraiment
une rupture par rapport à une certaine
forme de laisser faire qui avait qui
allait prévaloir par le passé je veux
pas entrer dans des polémiques parce que
je pense qu'au fond nous avons
effectivement le même le même les mêmes
objectifs en termes de couverture du
très haut débit du territoire en très
haut débit et surtout les mêmes
objectifs pour faire en sorte que nos
concitoyens qui sont ceux qui
aujourd'hui accès à un débit de mauvaise
qualité qui sont en dessous de 500 12
méga puisse avoir puissent être les
premiers servis et mieux servi
dans le cadre du déploiement du très
haut débit et ça ça fait partie des
objectifs que nous avons répété déjà à
de nombreuses occasions
il est bien clair que dans le cadre et
c'est bien pour ça que l'état s'est
dotée d'une structure de pilotage dans
le cadre du déploiement seront
prioritaires je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
a en conclusion de mon intervention
seront prioritaires les zones dans
lesquelles un peu à l'image de des
licences 4g les zones dans lesquelles
aujourd'hui le haut débit mais au débit
fixe et mobile n'est pas n'est pas
satisfaisant donc moi j'aime bien un peu
l'idée l'idée qui a été retenue en
bretagne dans le schéma où on dit on
fait une prise dans une danse et une
prise dans une tendance rural ou qui est
mal desservie en haut débit et donc il
ya vraiment cette idée que des plats
mans devra se faire de manière parallèle
et de manière prioritaire même
j'ajouterai dans les zones rurales ou
urbaines mais non non couvertes pour que
nos concitoyens qui n'ont pas que c'est
aujourd'hui un haut débit de qualité
soient les premiers servis en très haut
débit
demain et c'est la raison pour laquelle
aussi nous fixons un objectif de moyen
terme à l'horizon du quinquennat donc
pas de 10 ans mais cinq ans pour que
l'ensemble de la population et à cet
horizon accès au moins un haut débit qui
permettent de recevoir un triple play de
bonne qualité une limite que nous fixons
à ces entre 5 et 8 mégas mais qui est
aujourd'hui qui n'est pas du tout
atteint les derniers chiffres de l'arcep
montre bien que aujourd'hui seulement 50
% de la population a accès à plus de 8
méga donc c'est pas c'est pas une
situation dont on peut se satisfaire sur
la contractualisation je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure nous ne sommes pas du tout
défavorable mois ce qui ce qui me gênait
dans la proposition de loi c'était
plutôt la notion des sanctions qui me
paraissaient
être un modèle contre-productif dans
l'hypothèse où on a quand même à faire à
des opérateurs privés
et si on veut les congeler les inciter à
investir je pense pas que ce soit là
semblent la perspective d'une sanction
qui leur donne envie d'aller investir
notamment dans des zones de la
rentabilité n'est pas avéré donc je
pense que c'est plutôt sur ce sujet là
que nous trouvions que la proposition de
loi méritait d'être amendé et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons souhaité
rejeté les amendements qui proposait des
sanctions et que nous nous orientons pas
à verser ce vers cette solution
ensuite les régions qui se défausse sur
les communautés de communes
oui mais là aussi nous avons souhaité
qu'il y ait un rôle clair parce qu'il y
avait effectivement beaucoup de
certaines communautés de communes qui
souhaitait ou non de grandes
agglomérations qui souhaitait pouvoir
engager des chantiers
enfin là vous parlez plutôt de petites
communautés de communes mais il ya des
grandes agglomérations qui souhaitait
pouvoir être et bien prendre en charge
le déploiement de leurs réseaux de leurs
réseaux sur leur territoire mais je
crois que les objectifs de péréquation
font qu il est préférable néanmoins de
s'en tenir aux schémas départementaux et
régionaux plutôt que et de donner donc
des responsabilités aux départements et
aux régions plutôt que comme jeu sur ce
point sur le permettez je reviendrai pas
sur souza dit précédemment mais juste
sur ce point je visais plutôt la
situation de département qui pour ne pas
faire se défausse sur des communautés de
communes
donc c'est une situation où les
communautés de communes sont contraintes
pour être encore plus clair dans mon
département les communautés de communes
sont obligées de prendre la compétence
très haut débit parce que sans ça il ne
se passe rien et mon propos c'est de
dire qu'à mon avis c'est pas forcément
le bon niveau non une petite communauté
de communes soient obligés de faire
jusqu'à la panne n'a pas forcément la
compétence technique et la capacité
financière de faire
donc ma question c'est est plutôt dans
ce cas de figure où on a des petites
communautés de communes qui sont obligés
de prendre la compétence que j'enseigne
se passe rien est ce qu'il faudrait pas
essayer d'aller vers de recadrer un
petit peu les choses
baj
dans l'avant projet de loi des centrales
ou dans les discussions que nous avons
avec avec le ministère en charge de la
décentralisation nous sommes plutôt
favorable effectivement à donner des
responsabilités aux départements et non
pas aux communautés de communes et
ensuite pour les collectivités qui en
auront qui en est que ressentir le
besoin
il y aura toujours sa place possibilité
de s'adresser à cette mission pour
justement l'assistance à maîtrise
d'ouvragé donc en cas de parce que il y
aura sans doute des problèmes qu'ils
pourront naître dans certains
départements où effectivement les choses
n'avanceront pas suffisamment vite au
goût de certaines communautés de
communes et à ce moment là il y aura
aussi une faculté pour ces communautés
de communes sans que pour autant qu'on
compte que les départements soit puisse
juridiquement se défausser de leurs
responsabilités puis s'adressaient aussi
pour conseil à la mission que met en
place l'état mais il a la responsabilité
principale incombera bien au département
la compétence et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui le cadre n'est pas claire
parce qu'il ya une compétence partagée
entre tous les échelons en réalité de
deux collectivités sur la taxe copé le
sénateur retailleau ça je je les dis oui
mon la taxe sur les abonnements
effectivement ce n'est pas très en ce
moment favorable à mettre en place de
nouvelles taxes vous pouvez l'imaginer
même si les abonnements sont relate
relativement peu cher enfin moment
personnellement je sais pas c'est pas
quelque chose que je pousse c'est pas
quelque chose que je pousse dans ce
domaine là notamment
parce que parce que je pense qu'il ya
d'autres moyens de d'assurer le
financement à long terme de ceux de ce
chantier je crois que les nos
concitoyens sont attachés à et puis vous
voyez bien que toute l'innovation
actuellement des opérateurs consiste à
proposer d'innovation à des prix
relativement modique et et pour
l'instant nous ne sommes pas dans la
remise en cause de ceux de ce schéma là
donc nous souhaitons plutôt nous appuyer
sur les fonds d'épargné avec des prêts à
durée très très longue et des taux bas
donc je peux pas non plus là encore vous
donner le taux est exactement de qui
sera pro qui sera proposé mais mais
pardon maman en pleurs des proches du
dôme auditeurs ou du marché monétaire ou
qu'israël y sera plus il sera enfin je
peux pas vous donner un montant exact je
peux pas vous dire ce sera tôt plus ou
moins tant de points de base mais ça
sera vraiment un taux qui sera en ligne
avec la nature de l'investissement
la durée de l'investissement et qui sera
attractif compte tenu une d'état des
finances locales et des finances
publiques donc c'est vraiment on a des
montants qui sont quand même
considérable à on a un but bien après il
ne fait pas la péréquation
non non on est bien d'accord on est bien
d'accord mais ça permet aussi de
d'assurer un modèle économique de long
terme pour des investissements qui
seront rentables à un horizon qui pour
l'instant est pas facile à déterminer
sur sur la 4g et les contenus des
licences qui contraignait les opérateurs
à déployer en zone prioritaire
donc oui pour respecter pour faire
respecter et pour respecter les
objectifs qui ont été assignés aux
opérateurs dans le cadre de la
délivrance des licences 4g
nous avons vraiment souhaité mettre en
place enfin accélérer le déploiement et
vous avez vu que tous les opérateurs
sont en train de lancer des
expérimentations pour quoi s'agit-il
d'expérimentation et pourquoi s'agit
pour l'instant de grandes villes c'est
parce que eh bien le lancement de la 4g
exige de procéder à un certain nombre
d'opérations techniques préalables
notamment de travailler sur la question
des brouillages
avec la tnt sur sur les fréquences en
800 donc sur les opérateurs n'ont pas
tous des fréquences dans les mêmes
bandes donc il faut les traiter avec
égalité et équité
donc nous sommes en train de faire
avancer de faire avancer à la fois la
question de des interférences avec la
tnt avec les fréquences de l'aviation
civile aussi avec les fréquences de
dollar de désarmer un et et ça ce sont
des choses que nous avons fait avancer
rapidement
je l'avais testé hier moi même à la
haine et faire pour voir ce qui ce que
produisait les brouillages avec la tnt
et nous avons aujourd'hui des solutions
qui permettent avec un petit décodeur un
petit filtre de régler les problèmes de
brouillage avec la tnt donc aussi une
bonne nouvelle ça veut dire que même
dans les cas où il y aura des
brouillages on a des solutions
techniques pour faire en sorte que ces
brouillages soit soit réglée et qu'on
puisse à la fois recevoir correctement
la tnt et et avoir et recevoir la 4g en
800 reste la question du 1800 sur
laquelle là aussi nous avons avancé
puisque nous avons demandé une une étude
de la direction à la dgsi c'est la
direction du trésor pour vous examiner
et évaluer les conséquences en termes de
concurrence que c'est qu'une ouverture
anticipée de deux trains de la 4g sur la
1800 aurait pour bouillie lantern l'abc
bouygues qui détient les sept fréquences
et qui voudraient pouvoir l'utiliser en
4g de manière anticipée
quelles conséquences ça aurait pour la
concurrence nous attendons les résultats
de cette de cette étude pour la fin de
la semaine
et donc nous en tirerons les
conséquences et nous verrons si nous
anticipons ou pas en fonction des
conséquences que ça sur les autres
opérateurs
pour pour gouic donc la possibilité
éventuellement de déployer la 4g / sur
cette bande de fréquences ce qui
permettrait d'accélérer
évidemment le déploiement pour les
autres opérateurs mais vous voyez bien
aussi que tout ce travail que nous avons
accompli a permis d'avancer de faire
avancer les autres opérateurs dans le
redéploiement et a permis d'accélérer
les expérimentations même si pour
l'instant elle son compte elle reste
confinée à certaines villes ou à des
solutions business excusez moi je crois
que l'âge
j'arrive je voulais parler de l'arcep
c'est ça mais ouais j'ai un problème de
coupures de détenir sur la juste un
petit mot sur la nar c'est ça nous
devons chez nous devons rendre nos
conclusions premier ministre à la fin au
milieu du mois de décembre à la fin du
mois de décembre
l'idée que nous avons enfin c'est
vraiment d'avoir une pas ce que nous
allons proposer en tout cas ce n'est pas
de fusionner ces deux instances parce
que nous considérons vraiment que à
l'instar de ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays les questions de
régulation des télécoms s'apparentent
davantage à des régulations comme celle
de l'énergie ou du ferroviaire est pas
d'alors la régulation des contenus ou à
kuala l'exception enfin la diversité
culturelle donc nous souhaitons vraiment
qu'il puisse y avoir effectivement un
collège comment une commission commun
aux communes où un groupe de travail
commun sur des questions comme la
gestion de certaines la gestion des
fréquences audiovisuelles ou le deuxième
dividende numérique nous paraissent
pouvoir justifier un travail collégial
mais qu'en revanche la question de la
gestion des fréquences restent bien du
domaine d'un régulateur spécialisé dans
les dents dans les télécoms voilà donc
nous nous sommes favorables à ce qu'il
ya un rapprochement
pour travailler sur des sujets d'intérêt
commun mais mais certainement pas qu'il
y ait une fusion des deux opérateurs
d'abord c'est la position du ministère
du redressement productif que nous
allons proposer au premier ministre et
et nous verrons des conclusions qui n'en
tire mais en tout cas c'est notre
position
merci madame alors il ya deux autres
questions jeu bruno sido
madame la ministre je voudrais noter que
le gouvernement actuel n'a pas
exactement les mêmes objectifs que
gouvernement précédent que les objectifs
actuels de gouvernement recoupent plutôt
ce que nous avons dans les départements
ruraux que ceux des objectifs du
gouvernement précédent
je fais partie des départements peu
nombreux grâce à notre homme en
particulier qui était examinateurs j'ai
obtenu
nous avons obtenu la haute marne une
petite participation de de l'empreinte
pour les investissements d'avenir et je
remercie tous ceux qui ont été acteurs
nous avons les courriers donc de
détecter mais le bruit court j'aimerais
bien que vous assuriez sur ce point le
bruit court que finalement pas si sûr
que ça que l'argent viendra alors que
alors même que nous l'avons inscrit dans
le budget qui a été voté la semaine
dernière
j'aimerais bien avoir des assurances sur
ce point autre question je rejoins
monsieur morin faisait partie partis
tous les deux d'une commission qui
travaillaient sur la téléphonie mobile
au sein de la dg 6c se réunit deux ou
trois fois cette commission pour faire
l'état des lieux et ensuite nous allions
arriver au coeur du sujet c'est comment
réaliser finalement la couverture
intégrale du territoire là où c'est
nécessaire il s'agissait même pas de
question de qui va payer quoi combien ça
coûte et sais je sais même pas de ça il
s'agissait déjà d'établir quelles sont
les zones dans nos villages ruraux qui
ne sont pas couverts aussi basiques que
ça ensuite on aurait discuté que cet
instant
il se trouve qu'avec le changement de
gouvernement le royaume être balancé mon
propos depuis que le gouvernement nous a
changé cette réunion ces réunions n'ont
plus lieu
je vous ai écrit madame la ministre
comme ce mot rêve j'ai pas de réponse
c'est pas la question que je n'ai pas de
réponse vous allez me l'a donnée par
oral et c'est très bien quand est ce que
cette commission va se réunir de nouveau
pour régler cette question là je vous ai
dit dans quel sens j'ai pas de d'aller
chercher de l'argent prendre pour
l'instant mais de définir officiellement
de quelles sont les communes qui ne sont
pas couvertes soit en a chez toi non et
donc c'est très important parce que là
encore nous avons nous étions réunis la
semaine dernière au conseil général et
j'ai eu des questions sur la couverture
en téléphonie mobile de deuxième
génération parle même pas de la 3g n'est
de l'a4 donc oui oui
alors donc c'est quand même quelque
chose d'important j'aimerais bien
pouvoir répondre autre chose à mes
collègues de que leur dire attendez la
4g quatrième génération arrive et
problème sera résolu parce qu'en plus je
suis pas sûr je peux recommencer et ils
n'attendent pas la kadji il attend de la
2g madame la ministre vous pouvez me
répondre
très simplement sur ces deux points pour
ainsi je vous en fichez simplement vous
avez évoqué à deux reprises la bretagne
tout à l'heure et je voudrais simplement
apporter un témoignage par rapport aux
questions qui était présente à l'heure
nous avons nous effectivement travaillé
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois sur la
question de l'aménagement numérique sur
l'ensemble du territoire breton
et aujourd'hui nous avons une
structuration que vous connaissez
puisque je peux visiter la conférence
numérique de la mi novembre qui se situe
à venir souvent dire que la région met
en place une instance de gouvernance
régionale avec des objectifs très précis
dont un des points essentiels étaient
cités tout à l'heure à savoir une prise
implantés en zones fortement aggloméré
en zones denses donc correspond à une
prise qui sera mise en zone
des visiteurs ça c'est un point qui est
très important et c'est ce qui
d'ailleurs a beaucoup rassuré l'ensemble
des élus du territoire
il leur a permis d' adhérer au projet
régional la déclinaison après se fait au
niveau départemental à travers les dames
et les communautés de communes et côté
l'agglomération effectivement on les
incite aujourd'hui à prendre la
compétence d'aménagement numérique pour
pouvoir justement se saisir de la
maîtrise d'ouvragé conduire les études
d'ingénierie et se positionner au niveau
de la gouvernance régionale dans le
déploiement qui devrait nous l'espérons
pouvoir démarrer à partir de du
séminaire gouvernemental de février 2013
qui devrait lui qui devrait nous assurer
sur des financements jusqu'à au moins
2020 et je pense que ce n'est que en
mettant en mouvement l'ensemble des
collectivités qu'on peut le faire chez
nous qu'on s'assure du fait qu' on va
vraiment avancer sur le dossier
numérique est passé à la réalisation
concrète parce que c'est ça la
difficulté sachant aussi que sur le plan
du financement
on a identifié le cou à la prise à
hauteur de 2000 euros donc c'est un coût
moyen
ce qui veut dire qu'on a des prises qui
sont à 7000 euros une autre qui sont à
500 euros et donc la région apporte sa
part le département apporte à sienne 1
des financements d'état qui sont
maintenant arrêté et on arrive à un
résiduel au niveau de la collectivité
côté de communes côté libération qui
avait près de 400 euros par prise donc
ce qui donne un c'est clairement le coup
de deux sachant que ça représente des
sommes importantes aux médicaments mais
faut pas oublier que ces gammes lisser
dans le temps puisqu'on va pas tout
réaliser tous en même temps et de
l'autre côté on aura quand même
l'avantagé de bénéficier de dutroux du
très haut débit donc qui est fortement
attendue par tous essentiellement le
monde économique mais aussi le monde de
la santé le monde universitaire
d'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et donc il ya vraiment une très forte
attente c'est vraiment un élément
important d'aménagement du territoire
moi je voulais vous poser des questions
dans la ministre d'une question peut
être un peu précises mais c'est
intéressant d'avoir un petit peu votre
avis
nous avons aujourd'hui un groupe de
travail que je préside
sur les déserts médicaux et une des
réponses qui a été évoqué c'était le
fait que l'on puisse bénéficier de la
télémédecine ou ce qu'on appelle de
e-santé et donc c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui enthousiasme les le
monde de la santé
ceci étant aujourd'hui on dit ben voila
vous allez avoir une réponse vous les
zones un peu reculer les zones non
denses puisque vous allez à travers la
télémédecine evans réponse à vos
questionnements sauf que en sorte à une
première difficulté c'est que les zones
en question une fois de plus sur celles
qui sont les plus éloignés de
l'installation du très haut débit et
donc là aussi la réponse n'est pas prêt
d'arriver de jouer c'est un peu votre
votre avis sur cette question puisque
voici il y avait des priorités des
financements qui pouvait tout prévu
justement pour faciliter cette
déploiement de la fibre optique
merci une de natation evelyne didier
hiel merci monsieur le président de la
mpt la ministre pour avoir rencontré des
opérateurs et aime en particulier
j'ai plus l'impression qu'ils ont
l'intention d'aller au bout du cuivre
quand je dis d'aller au bout du cuivre
c'est à dire que ils veulent
rentabiliser au maximum les
investissements qui ont eu lieu et je ne
les sens pas très enthousiaste pour se
lancer dans la fibre pouvez vous me dire
exactement quels sont les freins dans ce
domaine
la deuxième chose c'est que de la même
manière ils n'ont pas eu des propos très
positifs sur les aménagements qui avait
été fait départementalement je
m'explique dans le département de
meurthe-et-moselle
le département a pris l'initiative de
faire une dorsale en fibres charge
ensuite aux peut-être à d'autres opéras
d'autres maîtres d'ouvragé de continuer
le circuit en tout cas le ca va jusqu'à
l'habitant pour l'instant avec du wifi
max et là encore eu les opérateurs en
question dans des conversations un peu
of avait l'air de penser que c'est pas
ça qui allait améliorer vraiment les
choses et que au fond c'était des
aménagements qui n'était pas très utile
et que ça pouvait contrecarrer un
véritable aménagement extinct à dire que
dans les deux cas je les senti très peu
d'entousiasme
pouvez vous me donner un petit peu votre
sentiment pensez vous que on va tout de
même pouvoir avancer merci il faut alors
sur la question du sénateur sido donc
pour le fonds le lait les engagements
qui ont été pris par le fsn sur votre
projet je pense qu'il faut vous rassurer
alors jeu va se renseigner pour savoir
exactement pour quelles raisons les
choses traînent
mais les engagements qui ont été pris ne
seront pas remis en cause et donc et
donc il n'y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir
sur eux sur les engagements de
financement qui ont été pris par par la
caisse des dépôts sur votre projet sur
la commission que vous évoquez le groupe
de travail c'était un groupe de travail
qui était placée sous l'égide de la dg
six bons qui qui était qui se
réunissaient mais en parallèle d'un
énorme travail qui a été accompli par
l'arcep
honnêtement ce groupe de travail était
un peu un peu de bizarreries parce que
la dg 6 coordonnées des travaux des
travaux d'élus en réalité donc on peut
évidemment s'interroger sur
l'opportunité d'en créer ça on est à
fait disposée en discuter à recréer un
groupe de travail mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui avec la création de cette
mission que nous avons mises en place il
y aura un interlocuteur naturel pour
toutes les questions qui se poseront et
je pense que
je pense que cette mission aura vocation
à répondre aux interrogations et à être
aussi le recueil des bonnes pratiques de
les uns et des autres donc pourra être
être un interlocuteur peut être plus
efficace qu'un qu'un groupe de travail
ne peut on peut si vous voulez en
rediscuter ultérieurement sur la
couverture 2g
alors on a je sais bien qu'il reste
encore quelques zones blanches j'avais
je sais pas si j'ai ici les éléments sur
sur l'évolution du programme zones
blanches
on a quand même entre
entre 2009 et aujourd'hui améliorer très
nettement la couverture au 30 novembre
voilà je vois qu'il retrouve 9 en 2012
ya 170 ans aux communes à couvrir 26
communes au titre du programme initial
145 en titre du programme complémentaire
donc le programme de couverture des
zones blanches
il est réalisé à près de 95% alors je
sais bien pour les 5% qui reste c'est un
vrai problème mais mais on est je pense
qu'on va on va accélérer l'achèvement de
ce programme
probablement avec l'opérateur historique
parce que sfr rencontrant un certain
nombre de difficultés actuellement on va
de pouvoir accélérer l'achèvement du
programme zones blanches blanche phase
iii qui va mal on est saisi de les
communes qui sont prétendument couverte
et qui ne sont pas issus de la recette
qui est partie nantes alors sur sur la
couverture mobile
nous avons demandé à la mfr justement de
faire un certain deux mesures puisque
nous avons créé un observatoire de la
couverture mobile mais pas seulement de
la couverture des déploiements mais
aussi de la qualité de service ressenti
un ressenti y compris d'ailleurs dans
les dans les bâtiments dans les
véhicules etc et donc non mais parce que
c'est en fait les médias c'est vrai que
la méthodologie de l'arcep ne correspond
pas forcément ne correspond pas
forcément à la qualité de service
ressentie par l'utilisateur
donc cet observatoire qui enfin les
mesures qui ont été faites par l'anfr
vont être rendus publics cette semaine
je pense un long j'hésitais à les rendre
parce que je me suis rendu hier à la mfr
je voulais d'abord échangé un peu avec
avec arnaud montebourg et pour qu'on
partage cette information mais des
mesures ont été faites elles sont fait
mensuellement et donc vous aurez cette
semaine où en tout début de semaine
prochaine
une mesure de la qualité de service et
de la couverture effective en 3g 4g 3g
des opérateurs mobiles qui permettra de
savoir exactement où on en est et qui
nous permettra de prendre les mesures
parce qu'après il ya bien des soucis fin
il y aura bien une question de
couverture des zones non effectivement
couverte qui ce qui ce qui se posera
donc non je voulais je me permets de
suggestions sur ce sujet une question
d'actualité si je puis dire parce que
j'ai des maires de mon département qui
ont reçu la semaine dernière à leur
grand étonnement un courrier du préfet
de région leur disant qu'ils étaient
dans une zone blanche en terme de
téléphonie mobile et que s'il souhaitait
que le problème soit réglé
il suffisait qu'il mette son 1000 euros
sur la table donc c'est des choristes
sont arrivés dans des mairies qui
parfois font 100 150 200 habitants donc
vous imaginez les mois que ce courrier
du préfet de région
mais voilà allez je je je je monte je
peux vous faire porter le courrier gelé
dans mon bureau que vous faire porter
tout de suite donc qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez qu est-ce que l qu'on rêve chose
ben je demande en moi alors on va
prendre le film donc lesquels elle donc
la conclusion le fils de cuivre non le
fils de fibres de fibre alors sur sur
les la question des déserts médias je
suis plus y avait mis sur le coup par
prise si c'était une question plus à un
constat on est en train là dans le cadre
de du travail de la mission de d'affiner
la manière dont l'état va subventionner
le koala prises pour augmenter les
plafonds et améliorer la péréquation et
le taux de subventionnement parce
qu'aujourd'hui le taux de
subventionnement réel n'est pas du tout
le taux de subventionnement théorique 1
donc on est en train de travailler sur
ce sujet là sur les déserts médicaux
c'est exactement ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure avec les huit agressions des
usages donc bon moi c'est un sujet qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur dans
le numérique j'en ai plusieurs qui sont
un peu mes marronne celle de la question
de l'indépendance et du maintien des
personnes âgées à domicile grâce aux
nouvelles technologies
j'ai tout ce qui est smart cities smart
grid
enfin réseaux électriques intelligents
et maîtrise de la consommation
énergétique grâce aux nouvelles
technologies
il ya la e-santé et la m santé même
maintenant on a des acteurs français qui
sont extrêmement forts dans les objets
dans l'internet des objets et qui donne
des perspectives à la médecine à
distance qui sont considérables et je
pense précisément qu en effet dans les
zones rurales qui sont précisément
celles où la distance par rapport à
l'hôpital la distance par rapport au
bloc médical la distance par rapport à
auch chirurgien spécialiste
international de l a plus grandes sont
des évidemment des hommes qui doivent
bénéficier en priorité du très haut
débit précisément pour pouvoir avoir
accès à ces services publics qui font
partie des services publics que le
président la république c'est en plus
engagée à maintenir et à développer sur
sur le territoire donc moi je suis très
favorable à des expérimentations locales
parce qu'effectivement vous avez raison
de le dire il y à des blocages nationaux
de certaines institutions du corps
médical parfois et moi je crois pas mal
à la halle expérimentations locales et
je serais personnellement très favorable
à ce que je donnerais d'ailleurs des
instructions plus tôt dans ce sens là à
la caisse des dépôts puisqu'il y aura un
guichet qui sera réservé à des à des
projets de ce type de cette nature là
pour qu'on puisse à la fois travailler
sur la priorisation des zones non denses
et des zones qui ont des projets en plus
en terme d' usage de ceux qui pleins ou
du type man de cinq personnes âgées à
domicile du type télémédecine ou hôpital
numérique pour qu'on puisse expérimenter
à la fois le déploiement de la fibre et
en même temps travailler sur les usages
et des usages qui en plus sont des
usages extrêmement une utilité
d'incontestables pour nos concitoyens
donc moi je serais personnellement assez
favorable à ce qu'on travaille sur des
sujets thème santé ou e-santé dans des
territoires ruraux ou ou de montagne par
exemple parce que je pense que c'est
c'est absolument indispensable dans
particulièrement dans ces territoires
voilà pour cette audition de fleur
pellerin sur la question de
l'aménagement numérique du territoire
à suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par 3
qui reçoit aujourd'hui nathalie
kosciusko morizet député ump de
l'essonne bonne fin de journée à tous